he asked me if Donald Trump's a happy
man he seems to be happy I think he
believes himself as much as we all
believe ourselves I don't know him to be
the kind of racist that he'll probably
flip who knows if he actually wins the
nomination it'll be he'll say something
like if the King England was next door
the British were next door i'd build a
wall that would make everybody say oh my
god doesn't you know nationalist not a
you know racist that he would change his
rap he would disavow his endorsement
from David Duke he would change I think
he's trying to win I think America likes
to Frank talk it's divisive but it said
that he's where he is it that America
buys into it so many people buy into it
could say oh I'm glad he's gonna be the
nominee because Bernie Sanders or
Hillary Clinton could beat him but it
could also say the damage he's done the
amount of hate he spewed up is is in our
midst it's around us people wouldn't say
to shit they say now if we're not for
him promoting it in a way that it's okay
to say this about Muslims about Latinos
the underhanded remarks that speak to
anti-semitism that speak to racism those
things you couldn't say as a candidate
before you know it we all the work that
people have done to promote equality for
their gender for them you know for their
race for their in a particular
marginalized position you know white
supremacy is a hell of a thing if you're
white male you can say politically
correct doesn't matter and as an artist
I never thought it mattered
but if it's not politically correct and
you're running for office and all these
political and social things come up then
if you're a woman you're in trouble if
you get you're in trouble if you're
Latino you're in trouble if you're
african-american a Muslim or Jewish
you're in trouble once politically
correct goes out the window the only
person safe is a white male and that's a
very scary thing that a candidate
doesn't have to be politically correct
because his job is to promote the same
freedom and equality that people fought
for everybody who's fought to retain to
stop certain kind of speech not from
everybody just from our leaders just
from the top down that we resonate
inclusive loving compassionate behavior
that's what we want from the top down
then people can have opinions but the
top down compassionate loving speech
inclusive speech and Donald Trump has
not given us any of that but because of
that he's gotten people to think and
then say and would be willing to act on
ideas that we are afraid would destroy
this compassionate loving the koala
therrien society that we want to build
up we worked hard to get to go to move
toward so I'm very afraid of his
candidacy and what it represents because
the damage is already done
you